now ai I know you've been talking about
it as well I want to know how you're
using it which tools you're using it
we're using Ai and some audio
translating my voice into other
languages Spanish Spanish and farsy and
German and French like I think every one
of your favorite creators will be
speaking every language perfectly synced
lips within the next 24 to 36 months at
scale so that's going to be enormous mid
Journey for creative thinking you know
just typing in different visuals as I
visual ual things especially for
internal presentations and decks chat
GPT for thinking or answering questions
like I I like using it for Trends those
three really stand out it's very clear
what this AI journey is going to be it's
an incredible infrastructure to our
society and it will change a lot of
things now ai I know you've been talking
about it as well I want to know how
you're using it which tools you're using
it we're using Ai and some
audio